[Musique]
et pour ce rendez-vous junior on va
faire appel à vos talent d'artistees un
concours est actuellement proposé
bonjour Mélanie bonjour Camille alors
c'est le centre Alfred devin de voisin
le Bretonneux qui lance le défi il
s'adresse à tous les vcinois bien sûr
mais les qutinois il n'y a pas de limite
d'âge les adultes peuvent participer
mais aussi les enfants puisque les
écoles de voisins ont été sollicitées
pour le thème rien de plus simple tout
est dans le titre si Alfred devini mais
je laisse Julie billot la coordinatrice
du centre nous en dire un peu plus on
s'est dit si Alfred devin voilà était là
qu'est-ce qu'il aimerait voir qu'est-ce
qu'il est et on a choisi une phrase donc
on peut la voir ici et je vois au-delà
quatre formes légères qui dansaient sous
la lune au milieu des Bruyères on s on a
beaucoup réfléchi sur la phrase qu'on
allait choisir fallait qu'elle soit
quand même assez imagée et que on puisse
retrouver différents éléments pour
construire quelque chose autour de ça
Alfred de vinis c'était un auteur
il a écrit des romans des essais des
textes des poèmes voilà et ça c'est tiré
d'un d'un texte qui s'appelle le loup et
donc enmis la thématique qu'il faut
respecter on peut tout faire tout faire
ou presque parce qu'il y a quand même
quelques consiges qui sont donnés
principalement autour des techniques en
fait alors il y a de la vidéo de la
photo du texte du dessin de la peinture
de la sculpture du modelage ou encore de
la couture largement de quoi laisser
libre cours à son imagination et Julie
me confia que des participants sont déjà
venus au centre pour débuter leur
création certains font de la
photographie et du body painting mais
qui dit concours dit sélection et
récompenses bien sûr tout à fait la
première étape ce sera une exposition en
mai pendant deux ou trois semaines au
sein même de la galerie du centre plus
de 40 œuvres peuvent être exposées et
s'il y a beaucoup trop de propositions
une sélection sera faite avec parfois
peut-être des roulement c'est les
équipes du centre qui feront la
sélection et il y aura aussi un prix du
public avec un lot qui est en train de
se construire
écouterz on a demandé à beaucoup de
musées de de nous envoyer des places par
exemple on a demandé à Pompidou beaucoup
de musées parisiens parce que on s'est
dit que c'était un cadeau intéressant
pour des artistes que d'aller visiter
des musées alors pour participer rien de
plus simple direction le site internet
du centre il s'affiche en bas de l'écran
vous pouvez récupérer votre bulletin
d'inscription et le règlement du
concours vous avez jusqu'au 1er mai pour
déposer le bulletin d'inscription elle
est gratuite les œuvres elles devront
être déposées du 1er au 6 mai et là
Camille il ne reste plus que qu'à la S
librees cours à l'imagination merci
beaucoup Mélanie de nous avoir parlé de
ce concours alors si vous vous sentez
l'âme artistique il ne vous reste plus
qu'à décainer euh pinceau crayon ou au
choix appareil photo merci beaucoup
Méline